hier fragen was sie vorher gewählte cdu
war das sieht man doch dass laschet und
alle anderen im grunde die gleiche
politik fortführen
die gleiche für uns alle anhänger zur
politik
ich habe vor langer zeit die grünen
gewählt weil ich total für umwelt und
naturschutz bin das jetzt da verkauft
wird das kann ich halt nicht mehr wählen
warum werden sie jetzt aber steht wollen
die afg heute das programm das die cdu
vor 20 jahren hatte weil das die einzige
oppositionspartei die waren in
deutschland ich würde mal vermuten die
viel haben wie haben sie vorher cdu
gewählt
ist das richtig na ja und warum wollen
sie jetzt auf denen sie nicht mehr die
cdu
eben weil ich diese partei als
extremistische parteien ansehen
alle die heute hier waren haben wir
irgendwann mal nicht auf gegen alle
machen eine einheit die waren bisher
nicht der treibt den mann
herr bosbach wenn sie das hören dass da
ein fd wieder sagt die ard hat jetzt das
programm das die cdu vor 20 jahren hatte
ist da was dran
nein das ist schon deshalb nichts dran
war die afb gerade übrigens gegen den
wunsch von herrn morton beschlossen hat
aus der europäischen union auszutreten
das ist das gegenteil von dem was die
union immer vertreten hat wir sind die
europapartei schöne grüße nach sachsen
anhalt und die neuen bundesländer die
wiedervereinigung hätten wir in der
kürze der zeit und zu diesem zeitpunkt
unter helmut kohl gar nicht erreichen
können wenn wir nicht hier zuvor den
europäischen einigungsprozess gehabt
hätten wenn wir nicht das vertrauen der
europäischen partner zurück gewonnen
hätten
in ein neues demokratisches deutschland
es war ich auch keineswegs alle restlos
begeistern über die deutsche
wiedervereinigung margaret thatcher hat
das anders gesehen als die allermeisten
aber wir hatten das vertrauen der
europäischen passen und eingebettet
gegen die gemeinschaft der europäischen
union haben wir das vertrauen gewonnen
und das hat dann letztendlich dazu
geführt dass in schneller zeit die
deutsche wiedervereinigung was damals
hoch umstritten war unter beibehaltung
der nato-mitgliedschaft erreicht werden
konnte dass exakt das gegenteil von dem
was der herr gerade im film gesagt